لديني المندائيه طقوس ومراسيم خاصه في
اداء هذه الشعائر التي تميزه عن باقي
الديانات والمكونات الاخرى في العراق حيث
يعد الزواج والانجاب واجبا على كل مندائي
ومن ضمنهم رجال الدين فلا يمكن لرجل الدين
ان يحصل على ترقيه من مرتبه الترميذه الى
كرنفره الا ان يكون متزوجا وله اطفال لذلك
يحرم الدين المندائي الرهبه
يجيز الدين المندائي الزواج باكثر من
واحده في بعض الحالات مثل عدم قدره المراه
على الانجاب او اصابتها بمرض وفي هذه
الحاله يسمح للرجل بالزواج بشرط العدل بين
زوجاته وتاتي الزوجه الاولى في المرتبه
العليا في المناسبات الدينيه كما يحرم
الدين المندائي الطلاقه الا في حالات خاصه
ولا يجوز للمندائي الزواج الا بالمراه
المندليه والزواج المندائي لا يكون جائزا
شرعيا الا بعدد من الطقوس والمراسم الخاصه
التي يؤديها ابناء هذه الطائفه